- Do you remember how inescapable pop punk
was in the early 2000's?
blink-182 was all over MTV.
The band's drummer, Travis Barker,
even had a reality TV show.
Pete Wentz, of Fall Out Boy,
was frequently on the cover of J-14.
Simple Plan even made a cameo
in an Olsen twins movie.
Eventually, fans and bands grew up
and pop punk faded from the
limelight in the early 2010s.
- Fast forward to today, pop punk is back
and Gen Z is reviving the scene.
Musicians like Willow,
Meet Me @ The Altar, Pinkshift,
And Kenny Hoopla have taken the torch.
Even Gen Z artists outside the genre
like Olivia Rodrigo and
The Kid Laroi are borrowing
from pop punk, resulting
in viral chart toppers.
- In this video, we're gonna dig
into just how Gen Z is
leading a pop punk revival
and make sure you stay till the end,
where we try to create our
own pop punk inspired tune.
(pop punk inspired music)
- Okay. So what does pop punk even mean?
Well, it's basically an offshoot
of punk that drifts away
from the heavy and aggressive
to a melodic and pop sound.
Some say The Ramones were
the first pop punk band,
but the Descendants became
the blueprint for pop punk
in 1982, with their LP,
Milo Goes To College.
("Suburban Home" by Descendents)
Descendants' drummer Bill
Stevenson cited his influences
as the Kinks, The Seeds, The
Ramones, and the early Beatles.
Without The Descendants,
bands like blink-182,
who pushed pop punk into the mainstream,
may have never existed.
In 2016, Mark Hoppus of blink-182 said,
"The first song of The Descendants
I heard was "Silly Girl",
and it blew my mind.
That just changed the
trajectory of my life forever."
- When pop punk first
emerged in the late 80's
it wasn't an immediate commercial success.
Then in 1994, that changed
when Green Day became
an overnight sensation
with their album Dookie,
which went on to win a Grammy in 1995.
("Basket Case" by Green Day)
- Following Green Day, bands
like blink-182, Newfound Glory,
and Sum 41 began to take over the radio.
blink-182 became one of
pop punk's biggest names
after the success of their 1999
album "Enema of the State".
The songs had a coming of age feel,
fast and driving drums were paired
with a mix of goofy,
but melancholic lyrics.
("All the Small Things" by blink-182)
♪ All the small things ♪
- Yeah?
- I was kind of like a closeted
fan of pop punk, for sure.
- When I was a teenager, pop punk was like
the cool music to listen to.
As the mid 2000's approached,
mainstream radio started
to shift from rock and pop
toward R&B and hip hop, with
artists like Kanye and Rihanna.
("SOS" by Rihanna)
- During this shift, a new
generation of pop punk bands
found an audience with the youth.
Artists like Paramore, Fall Out Boy,
My Chemical Romance,
and Panic! at the Disco.
These bands signaled a shift
in the sound of pop punk
as they took influence from
the emo and scene subcultures.
Their new moodier version of the genre
started to blur the
lines defining pop punk.
Were these bands were pop punk?
Were they emo pop?
While there's some debate
on where these bands fit in,
these artists use characteristics
from both genres in their music.
("crushcrushcrush" by Paramore)
- During this time, many of
these successful pop punk
and emo pop bands performed
at the Vans Warped Tour.
Warped Tour began in 1995 and started
as a skate punk music tour
with lots of third wave Ska musicians
featured in the lineup.
The tour soon morphed into
a predominantly pop punk
and metal core focused tour.
During the 2010s, pop punk's
popularity began to fade,
possibly because mainstream
radio began to favor hip hop,
possibly because the teens that listened
to the genre began to grow up.
Or maybe the bands found it
difficult to adapt to the times.
Hayley Williams said the
scene during the early 2000s
was "A lot of internalized sexism,
and even when you were lucky enough to
meet other bands who
were kind and respectful,
there was other that wasn't."
The genre had a diversity problem.
Black artists and women
musicians were rare in the scene.
Travie McCoy, the front
man of Gym Class Heroes,
said he struggled with finding acceptance
within the pop punk community.
"I was definitely a sore thumb
at a lot of shows in the early days."
Fefe Dobson, a pop punk singer,
said she dealt with companies
attempting to rebrand her
as an R&B artist, which she refused.
Dobson showed young black
girls that they can be
angsty, angry, and alternative too.
("Take Me Away" by Fefe Dobson)
- What was that experience like?
Just going back a little bit,
how did you feel that the
label tried to mold you?
- The one thing that
actually was the red flag,
was, I think they thought
it was a compliment but,
they coined me as Brandy Spears.
And that really bothered me,
because first of all, I'm not, you know
I love Brandy, love Brandy,
but I'm not, I'm not them.
So basically it's like, well, she's Brandy
because she's black but she
has got a poppy white voice,
so she's Britney.
And that's how they were selling me
so that as young as I was, I was about 15.
I knew that felt weird. That
felt weird to already be put
in a box and put in a category and coined
with a different name right off the bat.
- Especially a box that is just so not
representative of yourself.
Do you feel that pop rock and pop punk,
needed to be reinvented?
- I'm happy pop punk is back or pop rock.
I would say both genres, but
I would also say that like,
hell yeah. Why not?
You know, I think that we
also went through a crazy time
in the last few years.
We need young people and,
and anybody to come out
and be honest and shout how they feel and
and be unapologetic because
we've gone through too much.
And we were hit with so much
in the last three years that
you know, we had to come back musically.
With you know, just honest, raw emotion.
- During the pandemic, TikTok
began introducing pop punk
to a new generation and
also brought nostalgia
to the genre's long term fans.
Many 2000s pop punk classics from bands
like All Time Low and
Paramore went viral on the app
with videos using their songs,
getting up to 3 million likes
("Dear Maria, Count Me
In" by All Time Low)
- With its growing community,
we're seeing more diversity
and TikTokers are utilizing
hashtags like #blackalt and #altPOC,
which have gained millions of views.
These include bands like
De'Wayne, Magnolia Park,
Kenny Hoopla, Cherym,
and Meet Me @ the Altar.
("Brighter Days (Are Before
Us)" by Meet Me @ the Altar)
- No one found out about us at all
for like four or five years,
because we were over here
like putting our music
on Spotify and all that.
We were kind of just like
screaming, like, "Hey, we exist!"
But no one was hearing it.
So I'm definitely sure that
there's other bands out there
that are like that,
which I'm glad our band
getting recognition is
gonna help them, like
know that they have a space
where they can reach out
and people will actually hear them.
- All these bands are in
their own little bubble
of pop punk. If you look from the outside,
it's all these white guys talking about
their girlfriends or ex-girlfriends
or girlfriends they never got, whatever.
And then it's just all the same stuff.
And then all of these
girls who are minorities
are also in the bubble,
but you don't see them
because there's not very many of them.
It's a community that like,
we can't really relate
to sometimes. So that's
why we try to make our own
and I think that's something
that we do as a band.
- Ladies and ladies. No gentlemen.
Show me what you got.
- Yeah, I think it's, it's awesome,
but also frustrating
to be in that position
of being the first. People are saying
that Gen Z is reinventing pop punk.
And do you feel like that's the case?
- It's so strange to see how much,
like pop punk's not dead, that playlist
on Spotify, has changed,
because originally
that was only bands, only bands up there.
But now like more than
half of it is solo artists
who just have pop punk
instrumentals behind it.
So it's like, it's definitely changing
and it's so weird to see it change
so drastically over the last couple years.
- What are some positive reinventions
that you're seeing happen?
- I do like that some
artists are starting to sound
more like the early 2000s.
Like any Amanda Binds
movie, like soundtrack.
- Yes!
- That, that kinda, that
kinda sound is coming back
which is always so nostalgic
and sounds so good.
- Gen Z's Disney upbringing
has also been a huge
influence in the revival today.
They're influenced by Disney
stars like Demi Levato
and Miley Cyrus, who
released pop rock albums
early on in their careers.
("7 Things" by Miley Cyrus)
- While pop rock isn't
the same as pop punk,
Disney pop rock was many young girls'
first introduction to alternative rock.
And today we're seeing many young women
involved in the revival of pop punk.
Can you name the songs that you wrote
for these big Disney stars
and how did Disney get
their hands on the songs?
- For Miley it was "Start All Over".
For Selena, it was a song called
"As a Blonde", "Round and
Round" was another one.
- Such a good song.
- Well, I had an album called Sunday Love
that I wrote in LA. There
were songs that were
on that album, that are on the album,
you could hear my version of them,
that got picked up by these girls.
("Start All Over" by Miley Cyrus)
- That Disney influence
still exists today.
Ex Disney star Olivia
Rodrigo released a pop punk
inspired single that
dominated charts in 2021.
("Good 4 U" by Olivia Rodrigo)
- Another young star in
the pop punk revival is
Willow, who released her dance track
"Whip My Hair" back in 2010.
("Whip My Hair" by Willow)
- Willow's newest track, Transparent Soul,
has blown up on TikTok and features
a heavy pop punk aesthetic.
("Transparent Soul" by
Willow feat. Travis Barker)
Pop punk has also influenced
many of today's rap stars.
Artists like Lil Uzi Vert and Juice Wrld
have cited pop punk bands
as major inspirations.
Gen Z has shown the industry
that they still want
their pop punk loud and
catchy, but for the leaders
of the scene to reflect the
diverse society we live in.
Okay. So wait, our, the song.
- Yes. Let's talk about the song
- I peep the guitar progression
is very typical of pop punk.
- Yeah. I chose a very
hooky like very basic
chord progression and it was fun.
Nice.
Okay.
- I'm going to play bass on it.
I gotta record some drums on
it and it's gonna be such a,
it's gonna be a real small kick.
- When you sing, just let yourself go.
Like, you know, all that
angst that you have,
channel that and belt.
♪ You're never growing up at all ♪
♪ In a sad way, you're absurd ♪
♪ It's pathetic, you're the worst ♪
♪ You're never growing up at all ♪
- The concept I'm working with is
calling out the hypocrisy
of people, of society.
♪ You are lying to yourself ♪
♪ Never find your way out of this ♪
- As always, thanks for watching.
We want to hear what your
favorite pop punk tracks are.
If you'd like you can submit
a video of you telling us
your favorite songs at the
link in our description.
Here are your submissions
from our last video,
where we asked you
what your favorite backing
vocals in a song are.
- One of the best backing
vocals, that have been
a very very big inspiration to me,
has been the D'Angelo Voodoo album.
Really anything on that album.
- Oh, we need to talk about Lala Lala
and more specifically their
song, "Color of the Pool".
- Janet Jackson "LUV"
from her Feedback Album.
- "The Whaler" by a band called Thrice.
(fast paced drums)